il s'excuse aujourd'hui on se retrouve
sur hunt est elle un jeu d'horreur ma
foi plutôt indépendant d'après cette
qualité graphique qui laisse à désirer
alors pour le moins y'a pas de son e
jeux supportant dans le mixeur et tous y
en a donc je passe est plutôt bizarre
quality up sauter comme fuck mais
c'était de l'allemand bref allez vas
t'en ville un carton 2 michard de chaque
carton kouakou tôle des daubes et tu
arrêtes des gardons qu'il dise appuyez
sur entrée pour utiliser utiliser le
vide
comment ça se passe à l'interrupteur a
alors pardon excuse moi tu as vu la
télécommande elle qui suit la vie de
table normale et votre problème sur est
sublime olala ça va exploser oreilles on
va commencer par baisser le saut l'homme
qui avait peur d'une clé excuse moi tu
vois pas que tu déranges j'aime pas les
couilles tu rejoins de lui le carton
fallait aller tu rejoins dans le bus le
carton c'est parti on y va voilà comme
ça bon continue en ouvrons cette porte
au quai de maintenant je m'entends
marché voilà donc ça c'est la pièce où
tu n'entends pas t'es pas très bien
qu'est ce qui se passe ici
gros gros soirée temps c'est encore trop
fort l'homme qui se chie dessus
l'afoc
ok ça va ok donc qu ils prennent leur
tasse avec leurs pieds quoi ya pas de
problème ça se passe bien puis je me
joindre à vous s'il vous plaît à vous je
te fais un tour et qui fait ouais el
cheikh au revoir alors jean laporte je
laisse dans leur art qu'est ce qui se
passe ici
ok d'espèces de longues marches bonsoir
à tout ça ok une valve d'or loyer donc
il faut une clé pour ouvrir cette porte
juillet car m'explique où est la clé où
la clé va pouvoir bien aller sur cette
porte quoi
j'aimerais savoir alors ok to open
d'accord sk une porte qui s'ouvre sans
clé dans cette maison a oui celle ci
très bien alors est ce qu'il ya un
squelette posé sur le lit non absolument
pas faut pas aux vrais cette armoire
non
j'utilise je comprends pas est ce que je
suis en train de passer l'aspirateur
je ne sais pas c'est que ces brutes pas
honte avait dit pas sauter surtout l'iaa
avait des garçons allaient continuer au
hockey j'ai passé l'aspirateur sur un
cadavre tout va bien dans cette maison à
qu'il y aura inscrit moeurs avec une clé
dans un ennemi noir mais oui mais tout à
fait ce que je pourrais pas c'est par là
absolument pas on va passer par là bas
alors c'est peut-être ouvrir la porte
valeureuse pour tes belles bosses tu
fais à moi ah ah ah oui alors attention
à vous j'ai une arme à et va monter sur
cette citerne
histoire de faire plus grand de paraître
plus imposants qui va ce match d'hier je
suis juste un fou qui picote tapas où je
dois aller exactement un truc ok donc ce
mec slide sur les armoires quoi il fait
du surf sur les armoires qu est votre
problème à j'ai pris une clé ah oui
aujourd hui
ok je suis plus qu'actuellement je
soulève des cabines téléphoniques a pas
de problème quoi maman tu veux te ramène
ton portable n'y a pas de problème tient
je t'avais de la capitale avec eric et
aux open web aller ce mauvais au ça
suffit mais ça suffit la porte belvèze
tu arrêtes maintenant attention
attention tu as
à tintin ok je me suis seul je vais la
pression mais c'est quoi ça qu'est ce
que ça fait quand j'appuie sur entrée ok
ok to open non mais oui mais [ __ ] mais
qu'il ouvre la porte avec ses pieds vers
l'arrière quoi c'est carrément
inadmissible mais arrête d'ouvrir cette
porte avec ton pied ça suffit les
conneries je voudrais juste une simple
clef assez peut-être derrière ce truc en
fait la clé pousse toi ou alors on
refait la déco de la chambre valérie
damidot est là actuellement
excusez moi au alors c'est ça qu'on
faisait
c'est ça le petit bruit en fait on
passait pas l'aspirateur on active et à
lever fait qd quand vous voulez savoir
ça bon ça suffit quand même je peux
circuler tranquillement chez moi ou quoi
comment vas-tu la mort ça va hawn [ __ ]
c'était des lits superposés je crois en
plus s'il ya des gens dont ils sont
carrément mort quoi avec moi ah bah
voilà ce que ça faisait ça ouvrait des
conduits ok les gens ont fait une bombe
eux
alors on va par ou une sorte d'énorme
levier aux [ __ ] je me déplace je suis
bloqué c'est une blague
c'est une blague mais plus tard le viet
à deux mètres de moi je suis bloqué
arrête je vis laine gris ça suffit
[ __ ] je dois tout recommencer quoi ok
cette fois par soir et à thouaré un bond
voici de retour dans l'endroit où nous
étions extrêmement bloqué au sol à cause
d'une d'une sorte de grille finalement
au par contre au nom mais non mais on
peut plus bouger quoi ça va le jeu le
plus payé du monde
j'aimerais aller jusqu'où l'oubli
s'il vous plaît quelques uns vantant et
je peux pas bouger quoi mais borges
attendait qui va sous l'eau 3 secondes
et respire comme ça en sortant
personne personne soit possible à moins
qu'ils soient dans une sorte d'acide
citrique aller là ok on fait la
technique je roule ma tête sur le
clavier en espérant qu'il se passe
quelque chose très bien voir les gens
c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo je suis
désolé en même temps il ya une sorte de
gros bugs bizarre dans l'eau allez je
vous dis à bientôt tout le monde dise
lagarde